always disober what you do drunk and
will teach you to keep your mouth shut
hemingway said that
yes he did
and he said it to me
i don't want you to go to canada
tomorrow for the podcast it's what i do
i travel around and i interview weird or
interesting people so look at you crazy
canucks wandering wallace takes a
raunchy road trip up to the great white
north
hello i'm an old man who has enjoyed a
long and storied life at sea
and after eons of oceanic adventure i
know i do not wish to spend my remaining
years alone
when i have such stories to share how
far is buy frost from here let's boot
two hours from here it's a boot two
hours away i hate american guys
good evening
it's nice to meet you
could i interest you in some tea
so what happened after the boat sank i
was alone and then something very swift
and frightening moved by me
a walrus saved your life
the walrus is far more evolved than any
man i ever know
present company included thank you
you're welcome
wouldn't you
they're
there
and we all ride mr tuff
he hasn't called me in three days i'm
worried
why are you doing this
are you really mourning your humanity i
don't understand
who in the hell would want to be human
oh
this guy wants to turn into an animal or
something
you